avec jean bédard qui est le président de
sport cinq groupes qui gèrent la cage
brasserie sportive bonsoir monsieur
bédard bonsoir
est ce que les restaurateurs je pense
qu'on sent une impatience que les
restaurateurs ont le goût de rouvrir de
reprendre leurs activités
est ce que vous trouvez qu'on devrait
avoir aujourd'hui un plan un calendrier
je pense à tout le moins il faut
commencer à travailler sur ce plan là il
ya eu évidemment on était prêt à le
perdre cinq semaines a commencé à avoir
une discussion là-dessus malheureusement
la troisième vague est arrivée les
variantes sont arrivés mais l'homme est
un comme vous avez dit je pense la
vaccination va bon train au québec
le beau temps s'en vient aussi qu'on va
avoir un été mais pour une instru gamme
la date probablement celle qui a été le
plus affecté par cette pandémie dont on
a besoin de commencer à avoir une
prévisibilité piste un peu pour ça en
fin de semaine le con qu'on a demandé
premièrement de commencer par
l'ouverture des terrasses parce qu'on
nous dit des mecs que la propagation ou
un grande à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
calendrier pour la réouverture complète
de notre de notre secteur à partir de
canne et terrasses ben en fait je dirais
que je commence à faire beau le sort
garde d'ici deux trois semaines
le beau temps va être là aussi de toute
façon les gens ce qu'ils font en ce
moment ils vont chercher des langues
dans les restaurants ils vont dans les
pattes dans des endroits qui sont pas de
ces remarques à dribble savoir augmenter
plus que le beau temps va avoir iv donc
pourquoi on pourrait pas leur donner la
permission des terrasses comme chez nous
on a des mesures qui sont en place de
distanciation à des menus ce des besoins
sanitaires qu'on était habitué de faire
leur disons avait elle été passée donc
c'est ce qu'on veut qu'on peut discuter
puis la bonne nouvelle c'est que le
gouvernement on sent vraiment qu'ils
sont prêts à le faire le timing était
bon je pense d'en parler en fin de
semaine parce que déjà les discussions
ont commencé cette semaine
vous vous êtes prêt à rouvrir qu'un bain
nous en faire ça prend quand même un
certain temps avant d'ouvrir aussi je
pense que les gens qui pensent qu'un
reste à gaza pas quelques jours et
ouvriront du mois je peux qualifier d
expérience quand même assez difficile
quand on a décidé d'ouvrir dans exemple
dans la région de québec je pense qu'on
eu dix jours pour se préparer on eu des
problèmes d'approvisionnement lorsqu'il
nous inquiète beaucoup en ce moment
c'est qu'on sait que cet été
les gens adorent tournoi
carême on va avoir la main d'oeuvre pour
offrir un service de qualité
les jeunes finissent leurs études en ce
moment les cégeps et des universités ces
jeunes là sont à la recherche d'emploi
n'a besoin de quelques semaines pour
embaucher les formes et moi j'ai des
employés que ça fait sept mois que n'ont
pas travaillé et souvient pas du menu
souviennent pas de la façon d'opérer
avec l'informatique donc on a besoin de
quelques semaines pour justement est en
mesure de bien se préparer pour un
retour graduel avec les terrasses et
tout ça nous permettrait d'envisager un
été à la hauteur de ce qu'on est capable
de faire la restauration est ce que les
terrasses de tous les restaurants peu
importe qu'ils soient en zone rouge
rouge foncé orange pourrait ouvrir cet
été je pense qu'on pourrait le faire de
façon sécuritaire parce que le bottin et
l'or les gens vont être dehors de toute
façon il ya des couvre-feux parce que
encore une fois l'homme à un couvre-feu
à 9h30 qui permet d'éviter justement que
les soirées ces tirs qui se trouvait là
c'est peut-être là que ça peut être un
peu plus dangereux tard en soirée faire
parce qu'on a des conditions en ce
moment et dans des secteurs aussi comme
je pense que centre-ville de montréal à
québec ce sont grandes à l'idée des
endroits que ça va être plus longs à
retrouver le niveau qui avait élevé de
le faire je pense que ce serait sage
pour elle permettra en même temps aux
restaurateurs de commencer
tranquillement repartir la machine
oui on fait du décalco en fait de la
livraison mais comme on dit dans
l'industrie là on est tanné le chemin
seulement 2 juste faire des boîtes nous
notre travail c'est d'accueillir des
clients chez nous est-ce que vous
demander la levée du couvre-feu n'a
absolument pas le dépôt n'est pas là je
pense que c'est le zew koehler a bien
fonctionné parce qu'effectivement je
pense qu'on s'en sort très bien au
québec son regard de ce qui se passe
dans les autres provinces
mais je pense que de pouvoir ouvrir dans
le jour quand il fait beau
de façon sécuritaire ça sera un premier
pop évidemment que seule la santé
publique va voir l'évolution de la
pandémie
ce sera à eux déterminés c'est quand le
bon temps le pauvre pour la vie des
autres restrictions
est ce que vous croyez qu'on devrait
avoir une forme de passeport pour
accéder à des commerces comme des
restaurants au québec des passeports je
pars je pense aux passeports vaccinale
mais je pensais trop tôt là pour avoir
ce genre de débat là on recommence en
entendent parler ou de rumeurs je pense
la santé publique encore une fois vous
êtes un buzz
eux de faire des recommandations nous en
fait on passe pour l'instant qu'on peut
découvrir de façon sécuritaire on l'a
prouvé l'été passé ça avait bien été
dans notre secteur
et justement on demande de commencer à
ouvrir et puis derrière sow va suivre ce
qu'on va avoir besoin de faire pour que
nos employés puis les clients soient en
sécurité vous êtes tannés faire des
boîtes repas blesse quand même si les
boîtes repas vous ont permis de vraiment
survivre au cours des dernières années
je voudrais surtout occupé à nogent on
ça nous a permis de garder plus
d'employés nos gestionnaires no no no de
cuisinier ça les occuper
mais je peux vous et notre but russe à
côté d'un restaurant puis voilà tous les
midis je vois leur devoir restaurer avec
personne maintenant on en est au début
on s'habituait mais l'on voit que
commence à faire beau intéresse nous
semble que si les gens peuvent venir au
moins pendant ces belles journées le
quitte à le faire avec un manteau parce
que oui je pense que les gens vont
vouloir adore ça pourrait être un bon
pot qui ont l'art de faire d'autres
choses que jose des bois des petits si
en plus le canadien canadien faire les
séries s'ils jouent aussi bien dans les
prochaines semaines ça pourrait être bon
pour la cage mais en fait ça pour être
riche tous ici notre raison d'être c'est
d'avoir les canadiens aussi restée peu
pour ça que laquelle j'étais il ya de
sotra est loin d'avoir des scieries
cette année de l'engouement oui c'est le
fun je pense ça va être bon accor votre
s'apprêter capuçon pouvait accueillir
certains clients oui comme on peut faire
au sein de bell ben ça nous aiderait à
mettre un baume sur les dernières années
qui est extrêmement difficile pour tout
le monde la restauration merci bien jean
bédard devrait d'abord essayé nous ce
soir merci merci bonsoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit